[Music]
I'll go slow enough and I'll tell you
where to Mark is
okay um so we know at some point in E
right that I'm going to do the inward
spiral right
okay and it we know it looks like that
okay all right so if
I go here and let's mark where his
shoulder is in the vertical plane and
let's mark where my shoulder is in the
vertical
plane you see I see this okay so if I if
he just keeps his grip and I do the same
spiral you can see what's happening to
don't don't do don't game anything right
now you can see how it's going up his
arm you feel it in the into his shoulder
and staying at his wrist you see
that you guys see that
okay I'll do it again and you'll see any
anytime his shoulder is on that side of
the Sagal plane to my
shoulder that's what's going to happen
so I'll bring him even closer
got it but we mark it and we Mark where
I am and you see it again it goes up the
arm into the
shoulder let's say I'm I'm here and I'm
going to gather a center you see which
way is it moving on that way don't
gather your Center which way is the
shoulder moving that way you see so even
if I had the even if I had the internal
skills you're going to move him that way
but we know he needs to
go this way you guys see that
okay
so we already know no matter if I do
this with his shoulder on his side of
the sagittal plane you're not going to
end up here okay now let's bring
him way fast
you see it okay so we'll mark his
shoulder he'll be his shoulder you're my
shoulder got it and he's way past do you
understand and I do the same thing and
you can see the shoulder is doing the
same thing it's going up to his shoulder
you see and even if I if I internally
capture in Center he moves that way you
see he's not going around me okay
okay so the takeaway here is you can't
do the spiral in any old place a time
just like in the last drill you can't
do the inward outward spiral any old
place in time you will end up with a
different anatomical positioning and the
throw isn't going to necessarily be
there what usually happens is your in is
always just go
do you understand it's not the same
thing
as he's going to
go he's going to go you see that he
didn't roll he got thrown over here and
then took
a biomechanic so he doesn't land on his
back that's me throwing him
okay so
likewise an
eel where this
works
is
here so if we're when I start to push
into his
Center his shoulder is going to
be in the same plane as mine you see
that and depending on the time you get
some timing variables it can be
here and or here so it could be right on
the line you understand okay right
before the
line right after the line because I'll
always be able to make micro adjustments
on where I enter and then how fast my
arm is going through the spiral you you
have some leeway in there okay
so I'm going to always bring him his
shoulder to the same plan I'll do it
again so let's mark
it and it's just right before this one I
don't know how far is
that uh probably 2 in okay that'll work
I'm sure within there sometimes it was
here sometimes it was here sometimes it
was here okay so let's just play with
eel
test we can still work on the forearm of
the inward spiral cuz it's the same it's
where the shoulder is different now
it's a little too far still that
way still too
far you got to bring it in
more got to bring him in
more and you so uh let's go back a
little
bit it's it's uh about meaning and
matching variables so how much spinal
displacement he has is going to
determine whether
I how far I go forward or how far I go
back do you get that so in other words
if it give me a lot of spinal
displacement if I move forward then that
thing pass me and you have to now do a
different technique
okay you have to be able to feel that
what am I feeling for I'm feeling for
neutral y okay so uh same thing if he
has little spinal displacement and I
want my foot to go to four he's going to
be on that side and I'm going to pull
him so you have to feel what he's doing
you can
control you see when you're internal
boom and you'll get it
okay but you don't you don't do the
beginner mistake of going um that was
too
far and you keep trying to M just it's a
feeling you feel what it
is
and when you have the internal skills
you can go forward you can make it
smaller you understand but what is where
are you trying to get to that shoulder
is where my shoulder is more or less I
get 2 in for
Virginia of mar for air okay let try it
again study it now with these
planes don't just do what felt right cuz
probably what felt right is wrong
he's getting too far past you
that's
better he's too far ahead of you
too far behind
you try to I I'm always trying to line
up the shoulder do you understand that
I'm not trying to do two Ines one way or
the other I'm not I'm not using a 4in
Spector I'm always trying to line up the
shoulders got that just like I'm trying
to put a bullet hole in the Bullet
Hole okay but if the bullet is touching
the line of the other Circle I'll
take it okay but I'm always
shooting bull hole and bu hole so I'm
always trying to get shoulder to
shoulder knowing hey bullet holes
touching that dude's toes got it so 4 in
it's still going to work but I don't
take advantage of that okay try it again
he's
ahead he's I'm sorry he's Behind
still so how are all the ways that you
can bring it in Taylor right so you have
a couple things is you can yield more
externally you could enter more
you can bring him
in okay and you can combine all of those
things but you're over here like that
that's too it's too far it's not going
to work will will you project him if you
want yeah you can project him but you're
trying to create a particular
shape so if you have to work all of them
I'll pull him
in and I'll pick up great you see that
you can do those things you can play but
we have
to understand I have to be in a
particular place at a particular time to
get the shape that I want okay try it
again
better use your eyes to help you at
first that's it
better use the
shape get out of the
shoulder use the shape don't push
through the
fingers foot
kind of overpass it use your eyes stop
guessing use your
eyes you over past it you see how it's
like energy goes out you don't have the
degree of penetration because you passed
it you're overpassing it keep going
you're culturally just doing Sugi
there's nothing culturally there's no
culture there's just the immediate
present use the
shape you've been doing it in the other
drill
yes he was way way not inured enough use
your
eyes don't just enter p
how's that making
sense there switch rolls
don't forget you have a technique
that what am I correcting you uh for the
yeah cuz what are you doing running out
yeah you're freaking just going out of
there
right all right if we
have
please and and this is the same thing if
his
shoulder is on that side of the Sagal
plane to mind when I push you can see
the same thing it's going up the arm
making him go that way and it it doesn't
matter if you can feel his Center he's
not coming around this
way so we have to do the same thing I
have to get his
shoulder there we go
so we have our thing and that's where I
push he ends up around
you here no go that way he has to come
around me move again any number of ways
you could do it right I can if he's
really strong right I can let him bu
wait for him to pass and then
go I can enter to there and then
go right you guys see you got the idea
but what I can't do is try it when he's
that far on the other plank it's not
going to work so what happens is you get
this and now here's where I'm supposed
to be but it's outside my young line I
can't get there so you have to do this
no let him
pass then you can just step
it oh here there it is then I go around
his
arm around
have to do
that we got to go small you see
no here this is y I'm going out from
behind okay let's try
and go ahead do the whole ad me
and she'll she'll let you know how far
she wants to go so you have to let him
know move a little way towards the
middle it was a little not enough
look at the shoulders
[Music]
you got
pass passing passing he's walking around
you better
[Music]
be the whole week Forin okay there's
nothing wrong it's it's not
like he doesn't have to work on keeping
his back foot there's a
lot
okay all right
usually if you pay attention the one
that I
use I I
don't I don't like this
one so pay attention just to know no
shape no stance has to be
wor see that so you feel
free to not have to do the cultural
footwork all that is important is that
his shoulder gets in the same plane as
my shoulder okay all right we move on to
one other thing on this
part is as you
throw you're
like make this strong okay there's a
wall there you see you can't you can't
push it anymore that wouldn't be the
hard and I can't move the Y hand over
okay what you have to do is go around
his
fo you see how I did that right
okay do it one more
time get his shoulder good enough boom
and I'm going to make him strong so you
don't you can't do that and you won't
let you enter you have to turn
like that okay make
sense you don't just like you don't get
to do this shape wherever you
want you don't get
to inser you want you have to turn
around
that that's how the grip turns
you
see I turn around that like
that no no turn around so watch my my
body turns around this is the
idea is the idea
so you're not
contesting okay now we pay attention to
the
hand boom it rests you see it's just
resting my body is going to do
this then I'm now not going to fight it
here he's fighting me I move it
forward you
see then my arm will be that little
terod
arm boom I go around it or move it
forward into the down position
if you use one plane only horizontal
it's going to get
small I use it so I feel it's going to
get small and that's when I start to
lower
it then I don't lose
[Music]
K get you out of the grip too
there's the grip escape and it's just
waiting to catch
it okay so we'll finish with that me
step not the final thing
okay yes keep the arm through the two
planes
yes round it
get your elbow in place it's going to be
too late try it again get your elbow
hand in place just not pushing on it
okay in place around it two ples yes
that's
it as one plane tightens you take it in
the other plane vice
versa yes
get your hands in place start
over just not using them but they're in
place
shoulder so it's not insert
Retreat I I did demonstrate the turn but
I do enter in the technique
use your claw to do that so that means
you're going to move with your hand as
you're moving your hand with the
CL so that wrist hand should come off
last okay
[Music]
watch the shape for your the dirty elbow
if you're going to do the technique have
your hands in
place that that means your left hand is
on top of their wrist and your right
hand is touching the
elbow just not using them just R them
there
there's no need to lift your left elbow
because you're not going to use that
hand right
okay I'll protect the radius you see how
it C the line you see that I want you to
understand the the hand positioning it's
not a freefor all either so as I'm going
to the side I don't want the guy to turn
towards me and close then I can't do the
other
technique the ATT is protecting the
radius close you understand you got that
okay then once he once he's going by me
then I come and cover I'm
here I don't want him letting go and
punch me in the
face come
back
go don't
cover you see
cover ready so my hands are not being
used but they're covering
you see I go around the contention
Point use the two
plays Big R comes
last go back little
um I want you
to roll
outward okay got the idea roll
outward so uh I and
[Music]
Cathy you're UK
should not be being pushed
out
nor pass me push
out their
elbow is going around
me this
way so if our cultural
habituation he tries to go
outward that
way do
anything just tightens the pin on his
face this is
still
resistance and you take it on the circle
so so his resistance needs to go
up we have upward
resistance go up and I'm moving it on
the
circle you can't let it get so
far and then try to get this
back you have to
keep cirle
okay
um two things or three things you can do
on
this um
one is you can punish you can punish
each other and uh I wouldn't I'm not
going to dislocate his shoulder but I I
have shoved his face into the map pretty
hard okay um
and the reason for this is and I've made
him shove people's face into the mat
too this is It's a martial
art
and while we practice non-c
contestation it is not
weakness and it is not
forfeiture the non-c contestation is in
the no
attempt at direct opposition
With Victory gain through an
overpowering I'm not directly opposing
the angle his elbow wants to go and I'm
not trying to overpower that angle that
his elbow wants to go but at the same
time he mayuk does not get to do the
whatever they want to do and
anybody who's training here long enough
he might remember because he's a very
nice man he was was a very sweet boy and
people would do that to
him come
here and I used to yell at you remember
like knock it the off make them go
where they need to go do you guys
remember those lessons okay and it's the
same thing
here cuz I can always dial it back as an
instructor hey don't break them and then
I'll try another means I'll explain it
to them and here's how you explain it to
them UK you're not supposed to increase
the energetic values at the contact
points so when the UK tries to go out of
it they're increasing the Y value at the
elbow Point you're not supposed to do
that that's not what you do to train in
the art via the ukmi vector so no that's
not allowed the other thing I do is the
techniques have a logic to
them and you can't violate the logic
even though the techniques are not
self-defense
responses they have a logic to them
they're not
illogical so the UK we've done this and
I'm sure you could find some videos uh
the UK who rolls on to their
back we just come in right into the neon
belly and right into here we have or e
as you're doing the pin or the arm
triangle or something like that to let
them know
one uh that's not your freedom you think
it is and we make that fire hotter
because it's really just a a lack of
awareness a lack of presence that allows
the energetic values to change that is
related to fear that's why we lose our
presence that's how we got popped out
following a cultural Instinct versus
what's actually the what is the energy
actually doing okay we showed them that
that was the frying pan here's the fire
and you tend to motivate a lot of people
that were doing that mistake in the
first place um to not jump out of The
Frying Pan it's not that freaking fact
okay um
so you guys want I think the
UK is rolling out out of cultural
habituation but two you don't quite
have the inward Circle or the inward
spiral at the elbow point to actually
combat that and maybe it's
because not
uncommonly that you're trying for non
contestation and you've made the mistake
of thinking that that's about forfeiture
and weakness and allowance it's not it's
the exact opposite okay you do non-
contestation for uh for power over the
other person that's that's what it is
it's a it's a power strategy it's not a
a weakness so hence it's not hippie
Jesus
okay um so keep this in mind as you guys
are doing this and he he tries to roll
onto his back I I'll go here a
straighten out for me all right and then
maybe I could tell that's going to bust
his face or his elbow so I'll come into
here and take the top mount and maybe
work some
choke and we'll just do that all
night okay and somewhere in there I'll
explain to them like don't give one over
opening that's worse than the other
opening okay if you look at the
technique the inherent logic in the
technique is that the arm is
isolatable that's why I'm using it the
arm is only isolatable because the
center is not
accessible hence when he made his Center
available for top mount neon belly his
arm is not isolatable I should not be
training myself to have a arm fetish go
right for the freaking Center and choke
that out that that's what you
want to train for okay um if you look at
the
technique and he's going to try to do
that mount on me go ahead and mount he's
can't do it because the freaking arm is
in the way but as the arm is in the way
the arm is
isolatable and open to eel so that's the
Tactical logic that ultimately you want
to understand and we're not making a
fetish out of an arm or ourselves museum
curators for some Japanese system the EO
becomes the endol there's a tactical
sense to things
let that elb
push see it
[Music]
not
can't let it get away